WAI CHEE DIMOCK: So let's
start by talking a
little bit about the film, those
of you who were there.
We realize that the film
was very, very
different from the book.
But it's great screenwriting
on the part of Faulkner, in
fact, as there are really many
clever transformations as
Leslie pointed out.
The lawyer, Bee-lips, in the
novel becomes the occasion for
a little joke about a dead bee,
and how a dead bee can
really sting you, really can
be a really powerful sting.
That joke then was repeated
throughout the movie.
So it's a very clever
transformation.
I would urge you to see the
movie on your own just to see
what kind of a screenwriter
Faulkner is.
It's actually very impressive
to know that he could write
something like The Sound of
Fury, but he could also write
the screenplay for To
Have and Have Not.
So it's almost two sides of the
spectrum in terms of writing.
So this is just to alert you to
the existence of the film.
But I also wanted to use this as
an occasion to talk about a
remark that Howard Hawks
made about the book, To
Have and Have Not.
in many ways adding
insult to injury.
There he was completely changing
the plot line of the
novel, but he also had some
ungenerous things to say about
the novel and about Hemingway.
Because he was working with
Hemingway, and Hemingway
really was on record as being
quite unhappy with the way
that his novel was
transformed.
So Howard Hawks claimed to have
heard from Hemingway that
To Have and Have Not was a bunch
of junk, and apparently
that was the excuse
for his completely
changing the novel around.
It started out being really
good for nothing, no good.
Then he suddenly should have the
freedom to change it as he
saw fit, which he did to
a staggering degree.
But Howard Hawks really began
a tradition of people saying
negative things about To Have
and Have Not, and we can look
at a few other instances of
people expressing a lot of
doubts about the novel.
This is one of the most extreme
Delmore Schwartz.
"To Have and Have Not is a
stupid and foolish book, a
disgrace to a good writer, a
book which should never have
been printed.
It contains passages of golden
writing, and the parts of
three good short stories --
when one of these parts appeared
in Esquire as a short
story, it was much better there,
and not broken up by
the interposition of a chapter."
So about as hostile
a review as one could get.
Although, I should also say that
book reviews are a genre
in themselves, and quite often
book reviewers feel the need
to be critical.
So it is completely within the
convention of book reviewing.
Here's another, to my mind, much
more perceptive and much
truer to the spirit of To Have
and Have Not from a great
critic, Alfred Kazin.
"A new Hemingway?
Not altogether.
There are passages and passages
in which the old icy
brilliance comes through with
the slippery rhythm, the
virtual assonance, the artful
grade of phrases fused with
such laborious cleverness that
the click-clack of the beat is
like a hiss...
(but also) an unusual
awkwardness, for this is a
Hemingway who is rather less
sure of himself than usual,
but a good deal more intense."
So this, to my mind, catches
very well both what is good
about the novel, and
what makes it worth
reading in my mind.
But also, obviously, it points
to some very clear defects
about the novel.
It's also a very good
characterization of Hemingway
in terms of the old icy
brilliance and the assonance
in Hemingway's prose that makes
it almost like poetry at
many moments.
So it's just a very good overall
account of Hemingway.
But also a special take and
very, I think very true to the
spirit of Hemingway in thinking
that it's both less
well-crafted, but maybe closer
to Hemingway's heart.
One more quote from another
critic, and very
understandable given the subject
matter of To Have and
Have Not, saying that Hemingway
was "one of the
least overtly political writers
of his generation." I
think it's a very interesting
statement.
He was one of the least
overtly political.
Does that mean that even
though he's not overtly
political, that actually there's
a kind of a deep
politics in the novel?
Not overt, but something that
once we look deeper, further,
into the novel, we'll get
to see that there's
some politics there.
So I would like to take that
as a starting point to as
whether or not To Have and Have
Not is a political novel.
And as is the custom in this
class, I would like to think
about it on two different
scales.
One is through the macro
history, that is the
background to the novel, and
we know that because Harry
Morgan had so much to do with
Cubans who are trying to get
to the United States in part
one, and then the Cubans
wanted to get back to Havana
in part three --
we know that the Cuban politics
is very much there.
Along with that and parallel
of that, there is also the
Great Depression in
the United States.
So this is very much a
novel of the 1930s.
These are the macro politics
that make up the
context of the novel.
Moving to a somewhat different
scale on the scale of
character, the trail
of character
and narrative technique.
I like to think about the
novel has different
permutations of "have" and 'have
not,' so in that sense
its really themes
and variations
on the title itself.
I'll be talking about Harry as
a Have Not in several ways,
linking back to the macro
history of the novel.
But then what I really would
like to make the case for in
the rest of the lecture is Harry
as a special kind of
"have," what I would call a
mediated kind of "have." That
is, he becomes --
even though he so obviously
a "have not" --
he becomes a "have" through the
presence of somebody else.
So this is what I mean by
mediated "have," through the
presence of another person,
either it could be Marie or it
could be somebody like Richard
Gordon, Harry gets to become a
"have."
So this is an argument about
Harry not being a "have" on
his own, but becoming a "have"
by virtue of either a
channeling process
by way of Marie.
And he is channeled through
Marie both because of the way
she thinks about him, and also
because of the way he looks at
her, and he is contrasted with
Richard Gordon, both because
of the way Richard looks at
Marie, and because of the way
Richard Gordon talks to
his own wife, Helen.
So it's very much a permutation,
kind of a dance
really, among the characters in
order for Harry to emerge
as a "have" at the very end.
But first of all, let's go back
to the macro history of
Cuba in the 1930s.
As you can see, the politics
of Cuba was incredibly
complicated in the '30s.
There were six presidents in
three years, so you are under
no obligation to remember the
names of the presidents.
I won't even pronounce
the names.
So I just wanted to give you a
sense of how long they were
presidents.
Most of the presidents were
presidents for just a few
months, in this case, less than
a month, less than just a
few months in the case
of Ramon Grau.
Just for three days in the
case of Carlos Hevia.
This beats everything.
He was president for just one
day, Manuel Marquez Sterling.
And then slightly longer, a few
months-- that's a record--
and a few months.
So I think that it's just really
clear just from looking
at the list of presidents of
Cuba between 1933 and 1936
that the politics was just
incredibly hard to figure out.
As I mentioned last time,
Hemingway was actually not in
Cuba when he was writing
To Have and Have Not.
He was in the Bahamas.
So it's highly improbable that
he would have been able to
figure out the politics in
Cuba in any intimate way.
He would have been looking at it
very much from the outside.
He probably understood the
politics of the Spanish Civil
War that he was covering much,
much better than the actual
politics in Cuba that
was his setting.
So as a consequence,
the presidents of
Cuba were never mentioned.
We don't even know who
was president then.
Instead, what Hemingway gives
us is a generic type.
This is the young boy, Emilio,
who is one of the passengers
that has to be carried back to
Havana after the bank robbery.
So this is the very dangerous
trip for Harry.
But he gets to talk to the boy
quite a bit and liked him, but
also kills him, but this is
a generic type of the
revolutionary, marked by
his speech pattern.
"'We are the only true
revolutionary
party,' the boy said.
'We want to do away with all the
bold politicians, with all
the American imperialism that
strangles us, with the tyranny
of the army.
We want to start clean and
give every man a chance.
We want to end slavery
of the guajiros,
you know, the peasants.
We just raise money for the
fight," the boy said.
"To do that, we have to
use means that later
we would never use.
Also we have to use people we
would not employ later.
But the end is worth
the means.'"
Emilio is a young boy.
But he talks like a
much older person.
There's actually a lot of
authority, and I don't think
that Hemingway is just giving
this to us as a caricature.
This certain kind of authority
that comes from a certain
vocabulary, a certain
speech pattern.
The boy almost didn't have to
think in order to say all
those things because he's so
familiar with that kind of
phrasing, that kind of idiom.
He's completely conditioned in
that idiom, so that it really
is second nature to him.
We can think a little bit about
what it means to have
that kind of second nature.
I think that most of us tend to
think that it is not good
to have that kind of language
grilled into us so that it's
almost a kind of reflex
action for it to come
out just like that.
I think we tend to be very
suspicious of people who talk
in this kind of very dogmatic
and generic kind of language,
that you can hear two sentences
and you know that
this man is a radical, and he's
wearing his radicalism on
his sleeve.
So this is a man who, in many
ways, we don't even know if
his true name is Emilio.
He just says to Harry, you
can call me Emilio.
Going back to that famous line
in Moby Dick, "call me
Ishmael." Many, many characters
in American
literature would say to another
character, "Call me
something." This is a very, very
minor local instance of
this, but we don't know
his true name.
He's just known by
the name Emilio.
That in itself is emblematic
of the kind of
character that he is.
But I want to go back to the
point about what it means to
have a second nature, and second
linguistic nature.
Even though our instinct, our
gut reaction, is to be very
suspicious of someone like that,
I actually want to make
the point that having a second
nature like that is probably
not the worst thing a human
being can have. It is probably
not the best thing a human
being can have, but it
probably is not the
worst thing.
Because it is a sort of
religious faith that is cast
in secular language.
To the extent that we think that
human beings need some
kind of faith.
It actually is very, very good
to have that second nature.
So I think that Hemingway is
partly caricaturing that style
of talking.
But he's showing us what it
means to have your being
within that kind of language.
It's a problematic kind of
being, most of us would reject
it, but it is a kind of a
viable kind of being.
In contrast, we can
look at Harry --
and this is the first instance
when I would like to make a
case for Harry as
a "have not" --
is that he just doesn't have
that kind of political
conviction.
He doesn't have the second
nature that is second nature
to Emilio, and as
a consequence,
that's how he talks.
"I want a drink, Harry
was thinking.
What the hell do I care about
his revolution, f-word his
revolution.
To help the working man who robs
a bank and kills a fellow
works with him, and then kills
that poor damned Albert that
never did any harm.
That's a working man he kills.
He never thinks of that
with a family.
It's the Cubans run Cuba they
are double-cross each other,
they sell each other out.
They get what they deserve.
To hell with their
revolutions.
All I got to do is make a living
for my family and I
can't do that.
Then he tells me about
his revolution.
To hell with his revolution."
It's a reaction that probably
most of us would have. The
Cubans, especially in the '30s,
that sort of revolution
would feel that way to most
people who were outside of it.
But the point remains that
feeling that way about the
revolution gives Harry no
alternative moral grounding.
This speech is almost completely
empty of any kind
of moral foundation, any kind
of political conviction.
All he can say is I want a drink
at this moment, and that
I want to make a living for my
family and I can't do that.
So it is almost a kind of total
admission of defeat
without having this dubious
saving grace of some sort of
political conviction that can
point to some sort of exit
from this horrible condition
that you're in.
I'm not saying that Emilio
represents a superior
alternative to Harry.
Quite the contrary.
He's deluded.
I think that Hemingway
is not leaving a lot
of doubt about that.
Emilio is deluded, but at
certain points in one's life,
a certain degree of willful
delusion is actually a very
necessary fiction that lost
human beings need.
It is probably better for Emilio
to die still clinging
to that political conviction.
This is what happens to Harry
when he cannot cling, when
there's really nothing
for him to cling to.
When he's relying completely on
his own mental resources,
and there's not a whole lot
for him to cling to.
He's a pretty empty person
left his own devices.
So I would argue that this is
the first instance of Harry as
a "have not" only in the sense
that he doesn't have that
dubious, but redeeming kind
of second nature.
We also know that the Cuban
revolutions, such as they
were, were not the only
reference point for the novel.
To Have and Have Not is very
much about Key West and Key
West during the Great
Depression.
So this is Hemingway's house, a
very beautiful house, in Key
West that he spends a lot of
time in later, actually much,
much later, not at this point.
But this would have been what
people in Key West would have
seen in during the Great
Depression, the bread lines.
This is one that is
actually from the
Florida historical archives.
Most likely Key West, because
Key West, which is a very
prosperous city before the
Great Depression, was
especially hard hit
by the depression.
So the unemployment
rate was 80%--
80%, of the citizens were
actually on relief, and we see
that Albert is someone
who was on relief.
So this is about the most acute
case study of the Great
Depression that we'll get in
American literature, except
that Hemingway is not really
talking about the Great
Depression in a frontal way.
We can look at the way in which
even the word Great
Depression, without even the
great, suggested to us that
that is an illusion to that
historical context.
So this is how the Great
Depression is
registered by Harry.
"On the booze boat, Harry
had the last sack over.
'Give me the fish knife,'
he said to the nigger.
'It's gone.' Harry pressed the
self-starter and started the
two engines.
He put a second engine in her
when he went back to running
liquor when the depression had
put charter boat fishing on
the bum."
So there are at least two ways
in which Harry, as a smuggler
of liquor, two ways in which
that is contextualized.
First we don't know about it.
We can only conjecture
in part one.
In part two, Harry is both
review to us as a smuggler,
but we just think that maybe
that's just something he
chooses to do.
But then it comes out in the
context of the Great
Depression that he goes back
to it, because the Great
Depression has made the much
more profitable charter boat
fishing impossible.
In part one he was still doing
the charter boat fishing when
he was cheated out of
$825 by Mr. Johnson.
That was still the charter
boat fishing.
That is no longer operative.
The only way he could make a
living is by smuggling liquor
into the United States.
So right then, that is the way
this very oblique, very
elusive way is the way Hemingway
indexes the Great
Depression.
I think that it's really
useful to think of the
technique that Hemingway is
using as a kind of indexing.
It's not a frontal, a full
dressed description of the
Great Depression, it's just a
cameo appearance that puts the
depression in the index of
the state of the novel.
But if it doesn't engage it or
put it in the foreground.
I hope that you guys will talk
about it in section, and why
he chooses to talk about the
depression in that way, in
this very oblique fashion.
But in this passage we can also
see that Harry is a "have
not" for at least
three reasons.
One is that he's lost his
original occupation, although
there's also the reference
that he's
going back to running.
So he must have been doing that
at some earlier point.
We don't know why
he was doing it.
All we know is that he had been
law abiding for quite a
while as an owner of a charter
boat, and now he's doing
something that is illegal
because of the Great
Depression.
So he loses his legal
occupation.
Right now we also know that he's
losing, actually, all his
liquor, because the customs are
on him so he has to get
rid of all his liquor that
cost a lot of money.
But not only that, even that
small detail about this fish
knife, even that is gone.
So in many ways To Have and Have
Not is very detailed from
the macro to the micro catalog
of all the things that are
being taken away from Harry.
It really is adding
insult to injury.
You lose in a big way; you also
lose in a very small way.
That's really the landscape
of loss that Hemingway has
created for Harry Morgan.
Just one another portrait of him
as a "have not," and this
is Harry thinking about he knows
that those Cubans want
to be taken back to Havana.
He knows that they're going to
rob a bank, because every time
he walks by a bank, he doesn't
want to look at the bank.
So he actually knows that that's
what's going to happen.
He's not so gullible as not to
know the purpose of that trip.
But he is not in a position
to make any other
choices at that point.
So I would say that this is the
ultimate measure of Harry
as a "have not" is knowing that
he should not be doing
it, but having no other
choice open to him.
"I could stay here now and I'll
be out of it, but what
the hell would they eat on.
Where's the money coming from
to keep Marie and the girls?
I've got no boat, no cash,
I've got no education.
What can a one-armed
man work at?
All I've got is my cojones
to peddle."
So this is kind of the ultimate
blow against someone
who would like to operate as an
individual is to be able at
least to make a decision based
on your own judgment.
Everything in Harry's judgment
tells him that this is not
something to do.
His judgment is not at fault.
His hands are tied.
He has to go against his
judgment and do something that
everything in him would recoil
against and warn him against.
So this is the ultimate
emptying out of --
every decisional process has
been taken away from Harry.
He loses material objects
like the boat.
The boat was confiscated by
customs after he was found to
be illegally smuggling liquor
that was confiscated, so taken
away from him.
Now we know that he has no
money, and obviously no
education, and missing
one arm.
So it's at this moment, this is
the absolute low point, I
would say, for Harry.
And now I want to go to a
slightly different trajectory.
What I like to suggest is
actually the beginning of an
outward trajectory.
The beginning of this outward
trajectory is going to be
very, very stark.
It is Harry as an ironic "have."
This is the moment
when we know that
Harry is dying.
He's been wounded.
All the Cubans were
killed by Harry.
And Harry was also fatally
wounded by
Roberto, the big Cuban.
So all of them were dying on
the boat, but Harry was the
last to die.
This is the moment before
his death, and what
he has at that moment.
"He was on his back now with
his knees drawn up
and his head back.
The water of the lake, that was
his valley, was very cold.
So cold that when he stepped in
to its edge in numbed him.
And he was extremely cold now,
and everything tasted of
gasoline, as though he had
been sucking on a hose to
siphon a tank.
He knew there was no tank,
although he could feel a cold
rubber hose that seemed to have
entered his mouth, and
now was coiled, big, cold, and
heavy all down through him.
Each time he took a breath the
hose, coiled, colder, and
firmer in his lower abdomen,
and he could feel it like a
big, smooth moving snake in
there about the sloshing of
the lake."
This is in chapter 20.
Chapter 20, I urge you to
read that chapter at
least a couple of times.
It is great, great writing.
When the critics admitted to
having really impressive prose
in To Have and Have Not, they
must have been thinking of
Chapter 20.
It's just a great chapter, and
it's about a boat with dead
men and the fish coming to fish
on the drippings from the
wounds on the dead man.
But it's a great description of
human mortality against a
sea of very vibrant, and
obviously, living sea creatures.
But the passage right here is
a description, and I think
that it maybe is a challenge
from Hemingway -- although I
wouldn't want to push
this too much --
a challenge to us think about
what it means to die, and what
exactly do we have at
the moment of death.
Harry actually does have
something, although it's not
anything that anyone would
want to have. He has this
rubber hose that is inside
him that's making
him colder and colder.
It is not a possession that
we would volunteer for.
It's a possession that most
of us would like to have
taken out of us.
But it's a possession
nonetheless.
So I would like to at least
put forth the possible
argument that because
of the kind of life
that Harry has lived.
Even though there's so many
strikes against him, even
though all the odds are against
him, the moment of
death actually is his own moment
in the sense that he's
living his physicality to his
fullest. But this is not dying
without knowing that you were
dying, although he does lose
consciousness after that.
It is experiencing that
to its fullest extent.
And just having that register on
every fiber of your being.
I don't know how much we want
to push on this point, but I
like to see this as the
beginning of a kind of upward
swing of the narrative.
That this is the moment when we
can begin to stop thinking
of Harry as a "have not," and to
start thinking of him as a
"have," although a "have" in a
very ironic sense, having a
possession that most of us would
much rather not have.
But from this point, I like to
make a much more systematic
argument about Harry as a
"have," and I do think that
this is something that Hemingway
is doing in a very
deliberate fashion.
So I would very much want to
argue that this is actually
the basic structure of To Have
and Have Not is to show Harry
as a "have" through
the mediated
presence of other people.
So we'll be looking at him
through the Marie, and looking
at him through Richard Gordon.
So what Marie thinks
about Harry.
"I'm lucky, she was thinking.
Those girls, they don't
know what they'll get.
I know what I've got
and what I've had.
I've been a lucky woman.
There ain't no other
man like that.
People ain't never tried
them, don't know.
I've had plenty of them.
I've been lucky to have him."
It's suggested to us that
Marie was a sporting woman.
That was her profession.
So she's had lots of men in
her professional capacity.
It is from that wealth of
knowledge of men that she can
say that Harry is, at that
point, is the best. That she's
tried them all, and there's
just no one like Harry.
So it's a dubious kind
of compliment.
You don't want to have a
prostitute testifying to the
fact that you are the
best when that
happens to be your wife.
So once again, Hemingway is
really taking away with one
hand what he's giving
with another.
But there is no question that
Harry has made Marie's life
the life that she's enjoying
that moment.
That she's having a good life.
She's having a good life
only because of him.
He is the thing that gives her
a good life and that is the
measure of what Harry has.
So it's a much more complicated
mediated kind.
He has something because of the
good life that Marie has
because of him.
And without Marie, we wouldn't
have been able to say that.
So this is the first upward
swing of that trajectory
towards Harry as a possible
Have. I would like to add that
is not just because of the way
that he's treated Marie, and
the way that Marie is
now having a good
life because of him.
But also because of the
way he looks at Marie.
So there is action coming
from him as well.
We can sort of understand why
Marie is having a good life
now, and why he has made all
the difference to her life.
So here, Harry is going on this
dangerous trip with the
Cubans when he knows
that it's the bank
robbery that is at stake.
Marie wanted to go with him just
to take care of the jugs,
because he has only one
arm at this point.
She wants to do something for
him on the boat and she wanted
to come along.
So he said, "All right," he
told her, And she got in
beside him, a big woman,
long-legged, big-handed, big
hip, still handsome, a hat
pulled down over her
bleach-blonde hair.
"What are you worried
about, Harry?
I don't know.
I'm just worried.
Listen, are you letting
your hair grow out?
I thought I would.
The girls have been asking me.
To hell with them.
You keep it like it is.
Do you really want me to?
Yes, he said, that's
the way I like it.
You don't think I
look too old?
You look better than
any of them.
So that's why.
That's why Marie has a good
life is because of the way
Harry treats her, and we see
exactly how he treats her that
he likes the way she is, and
he tells her that he's
worried, but he doesn't
want to tell her full
extent of his worry.
So he changes the subject when
she wants to find out more.
All this make Marie's
life a good life.
And it is all encapsulated in
this one small passage.
The contrast of that comes out
in that previous passage.
We know that Marie is probably
a big woman.
She is long-legged, big hands,
big hips, and so on.
We don't know exactly how big
she is until we get to see her
through the eyes of
Richard Gordon.
Then it's kind of a shock to
see this passage coming
through the eyes of a neutral or
hostile observer, although
not really hostile, it's
really neutral.
But a very unkind neutral
observer.
"Riding his bicycle he passed
a heavy-set, big, blue-eyed
woman with bleached-blond hair
showing under her old man's
styled hat, hurrying across
the road, her
eyes red from crying.
Look at that big
ox, he thought.
What do you suppose a woman
like that thinks about?
What do you suppose
she does in bed?
What does her husband feel about
her when she gets that
size?"
"In today's chapter, he was
going to use the big woman
with the tear-reddened eyes he
had just seen on the way home.
Her husband, when he came home
at night, hated her, hated the
way she had coarsened and grown
heavy, was repelled by
her bleached hair, the
two big breasts.
He has seen in a flash of
perception, the whole inner
life of that type of woman."
So Hemingway is both dramatizing
the process of
labeling people, the making of
social types, and showing
considerable doubt whether that
is a good practice, to
say the least. It is really
interesting that Richard
Gordon is a writer, so I think
that Hemingway is probably
thinking about himself as well
and whether it's an entirely
ethical practice even
to populate his
novel with social types.
I mean right now he's actually
creating another social type
of writer who doesn't care about
his subject and the only
wants to use them to write
novels to his own
satisfaction.
So this is --
he's both talking about Richard
Gordon, and maybe
expressing a little bit of worry
about himself as well.
But in any case, if we move
away from Hemingway's own
investment and his psychology,
possible psychology in
creating someone like Richard
Gordon, we can say that this
is a direct affirmation
of what a kind man
Harry Morgan is.
And it's not just kindness that
enables him to look past
the bigness of Marie.
It's probably not just
kindness, and
understating the case.
It's something else.
That it truly doesn't bother
him that she's so big.
When it's probably what
most of the women
notice that about her.
So it says something about that
relationship, whatever we
call it, it is one that
turns a big woman
into a beautiful woman.
And to the extent that Harry is
able to do that, he is kind
of a magician of sorts.
He has a kind of emotional magic
that changes Marie into
something else.
In a process of that
transformation, he also
acquires an identity.
He is the person who's able
to do this to Marie
and do this for Marie.
This is the ultimate measure
of someone who has
magic in his hands.
It is the lack of magic that
makes Richard Gordon the
washed-out writer that he is.
Richard Gordon was probably once
a very, very good writer.
He has admirers, as we see, who
are thrilled to meet him.
But at the point we're meeting
him, the craft of writing
seems to be on the wane.
We begin to see this, what a
bad writer he is in this
supposedly neutral portrait
of Marie.
It's that all he notices is
the size of this woman.
He doesn't notice the most
important fact about Marie, is
that her eyes are
red from crying.
He is solely through curiosity,
solely through
imagination, that he misses
the central fact.
This is when Marie knows that
Harry is dead, and that was
why her eyes are
tear-reddened.
Richard Gordon is such a poor
writer that he cannot see the
most obvious thing about Marie
in his eagerness to turn her
into a social type.
In this exchange with his own
wife, we see the fact that
he's a bad writer almost seems
to spill out, and has a kind
of an analogy in his relation
with his wife, Helen, who is
leaving him.
And this is actually one
of the great moments.
I'm not quoting you the full
extent of Helen's speech, but
go and look at page 185
when this long, long
speech about love.
It's dripping with irony about
what she feels about love
coming from Richard Gordon.
But that is the end of
that conversation.
"All right, I'm through
with you, and I'm
through with love.
Your kind of pick-nose love.
You writer.
You little mick slut.
Don't call me names.
I know the word for you.
All right.
No, not all right.
All wrong and wrong again.
If you were just a good writer,
I could stand for all
the rest of it maybe.
But I've seen you bitter,
jealous, changing your
politics to suit the fashion,
sucking up to people's faces
and talking about them
behind their backs.
I've seen you until
I'm sick of you."
So what kind of a person Richard
Gordon is can only be
registered in the full by
someone who is by his
side all the time.
That is the most accurate
picture of Richard Gordon, and
that's the kind of
person he is.
So it is a portrait that
completely cleans out
everything, that removes
everything.
His claim to fame, his claim to
craftsmanship, his claim to
writerly genius, his claim to
being a great romantic lover,
all of those things have
been emptied out by
Helen in this moment.
If we think about the symmetry
between Harry channeled
through Marie, and Richard
Gordon channeled through
Helen, it is very hard not to
come to the conclusion that we
need to have an alternative
definition of what it means to
be a "have," and what it means
to be a "have not." It's not
so easy to add a label to what
the criteria might be for
someone to count as a "have."
The criteria probably much too
complicated to be captured just
by one word, and that's
really the point.
The simplest way to put it is
that in order to be a "have,"
you have to make somebody else
a "have." Marie has a good
life because of Harry, and Harry
has something because
Marie has a good life.
This is the symmetrical
construction of "have" in
Hemingway's novel.
So I would say that, actually
Hemingway is quite often
criticized for being a very poor
writer when it comes to
women, and that is true.
In most of his novels he has
no imagination for what it
might feel to be a woman.
But this is actually
an exception.
This is an exceptionally
powerful depiction of the
human condition from the
woman's point of view.
So in conclusion, I would like
to bring up one celebrated
passage from Modernist writing
told from the standpoint of
the woman's point of view.
Now, this is just a little
anecdote that Hemingway
actually has great admiration
for James Joyce.
He saw James Joyce in Paris, he
saw Joyce eating with his
family and they were all
speaking Italian in Paris.
Hemingway was very,
very impressed.
So it is not unfitting to
compare him with Joyce in this
most famous passage in Joyce
Molly's soliloquy at the very
end of Ulysses.
"And I thought well, as
well him as another.
And then I ask him with my
eyes to ask again, yes.
And then he asked me,
would I yes to say
yes, my mountain flower.
And so as I put my arms around
him, yes, and drew him down to
me so he could feel my
breasts, all perfume.
Yes.
And his heart was
going like mad.
And yes, I said yes, I will.
Yes."
So this is Molly Bloom
thinking about--
it was a long time ago.
The marriage has really gone
sour in many ways,
affairs and so on.
But thinking back to that moment
when she agrees to
marry Leopold Bloom, and Joyce
obviously wants to end Ulysses
on that note, that very early
romance between two of them.
A woman's love for a man, and
a man's love for a woman.
This is not quite that.
It's the opposite of that.
But I would argue it's just as
powerful, even though it's not
as well-known as Molly's
soliloquy is Marie's.
"How do you get through nights
if you can't sleep.
I guess you find out, let you
find out out how it feels to
lose your husband.
I guess you find
out all right.
I guess you find out
everything in
this goddamn life.
I guess you do all right.
I guess I'm probably finding out
right now you just go dead
inside and everything is easy.
You just get dead like most
people are most of the time.
I guess that's how
it's all right.
I guess that's just about
what happens to you.
Well, I've got a good thought.
I've got a good thought if
that's what you have to do.
I guess that's what you
have to do all right.
I guess that's it.
I guess that's what
it comes to.
All right.
I've got a good start then.
I'm way ahead of
everybody now."
Hemingway almost sounds like
Gertrude Stein, another of his
favorite people.
And then it also sounds a little
bit like Hemingway.
Tremendous admiration
for Gertrude Stein.
He really does sound like
Gertrude Stein.
This is a kind of senseless
repetition.
This is not eloquent at all.
It is compulsive repetition on
the part of Marie, and that is
the compulsive repetition that
comes to his own wife where
she's had a good life and
that good life has been
taken away from her.
So both in fact that she's had
a good life, and in the fact
that she's going hysterical
when that is
taken away from her.
In both instances, Marie attests
to what kind of a man
Harry Morgan is and he
definitely is not a social
"have not."